to work at rush university medical
center there's a new rule get the job or
get another job
i think it's the right thing to do we
are in health care we should be
maintaining health and we shouldn't be
putting our patients at risk and even
though the risk of transmitting covid
from
a healthcare worker to a patient is low
it's not zero there are strict
exemptions for religious or medical
reasons but in general health care
workers are now required to practice
what they preach about 70 percent of u.s
adults are at least partly vaccinated
for covid19 it's 60 if you include the
children under 12 who are not eligible
for health care workers the numbers are
similar though at rush they've now
reached 85 percent we're trying to
decrease transmission of the delta
variant so
you if you come here and everybody's
vaccinated then you're less likely to
leave with the virus
rush stands at the vanguard of a growing
movement nearly fifteen thousand
hospitals about one in four across the
u.s now require staffers to get the
coveted vaccine according to the
american hospital association and states
like new york california and washington
have issued vaccine mandates for health
care workers like it or not vaccine
mandates work since chicago began
requiring a vaccination or a negative
test to attend most concerts more people
have gotten vaccinated and since france
began requiring a similar health pass to
attend bars restaurants and most indoor
venues millions more people signed up to
get the shot and that's crucial to reach
the kind of herd immunity that will stop
those new variants from popping up
still some are saying no to inoculation
and there have been protests across the
country by thousands of vaccine weary
health care workers
you have every right not to get
vaccinated we're not going to force you
to get vaccinated but you may have to
find another place to work
that's exactly what happened to workers
at rwj barnabas health in new jersey
which recently fired half a dozen senior
employees for refusing to get vaccinated
with more companies in and out of health
care requiring the vaccine to enter the
office doors each day
that leaves anti-vaxxers with
increasingly few options john hendren al
jazeera chicago